welcome to this video Val Mafia's 88
played him or her l once and lost and if
it's not in vain quickly okay yes he is
moving maybe some let's let's play a
little bit different and maybe our can
exchange snuff just wanted to do
something different and then you get the
exchanges love I mean I played this
opening quite often with wide so i
cannot really blame the white play on
being a being boring but then it's not
them jack citing opening to face hmm did
I make some move on a mistake Bishop d7
huh I don't know of course I can play we
should be soon tween a 496 yeah I was
just just confused for a mode okay
okay so what now maybe just go with you
six it's not not a big problem all this
to e to Knight f3 is a bit more coming
down as you want some influence over the
e5 square but okay definitely it's
playable what is doing night before to
get this traded maybe let's invest this
this bit of time to make sure we get our
bishop of the board so we traded our our
bad bishop and now we can can go from
here Queen d7 rook c8 normal moves nice
position is a bit yeah suffering is a
bit much of an expression but the night
only two is not not helping him yeah I
can maybe go night before here intending
night to d2 but he's got rooked you one
so it's not helping much this is
probably probably better Knight a5 at
the right moment can be an idea oops I
didn't consider that at all
yeah he's attacking be seven so maybe
just robbed the ad but now this isn't
this this is not really a night that has
many squares so it don't if I you are
not threatening let something like a six
here a six trying to trap this yeah I
don't understand anything here as usual
what's going on if i play a six in this
in this position a six-night takes luca
aid and resigns so this this cannot be
the problem hmm ok let's let's play that
and not waste any more time tonight a 6
ok this should be quite convincing
and they are gatemouth red was Bishop d6
so I don't know maybe the night was
almost wrapped night yes but I have let
me check let me check i can't play rook
a 60 k 6p a 60 i haven't won a piece
they are interesting I thought I would
win a piece but okay I can my initial
idea was to take with the porn anyway as
I have queen bee seven still available
Queen B seven rook c6 I can also start
with rook c8 and sort of asked him what
are you doing ago about queen bee seven
he really has no way against the pen I
think Queen a seven or queen bee seven
pinning the night he has no Queen move
where he still has the night protected
and Bishop and night cannot really help
him i think they are just basically
standing around yeah Queen B seven now
and this wins the night for her look
I didn't have any move available I think
allowing a six was really a big mistake
at least I'm white reside at least i
don't i don't think he he can allow it
let it's shaky i think he must just
retreat and this this makes 97 a pretty
useless move but i don't think he can
afford that he a six and black wins yeah
asics is a win it should be success just
too too much but should be six or
attacking the night the relatively best
latias night XD five now where you at
least get me get rook and pawn against
two pieces in a pretty good form for
black because i have my pieces are
coordinated and they have some ideas to
attack but this is what he must true a
master must do at least in blitz chess
this is something that you can
definitely fight for after this he
really isn't the in the deadly pen be
takes Luke see one Luke c8 and win Sam
okay i think i played this plate this
all right i'm not sure about some of
some of his moves for for example it's
it's it's a question maybe let's say
here maybe he should invest a moment to
to to secure this Bishop from from
getting exchange I can play here maybe
and get the bishop pair over there but
keeping this light squared Bishop basis
and I think white and quite quite good
here yeah it's still about equal here I
mean I'm glad to have the light squared
Bishop traded but of course it's a very
simplified position he really got
himself into trouble when he went with
the snide cc7 business
okay thanks for watching